[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gagner que m'ont fait du mal encore
amplifié quelqu'un vite famille s'est
pas fait
regarde j'ai une autre photo d'elle
alors qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est moi je me
suis pas encore vraiment fait beaucoup
d'amis qu'on rachète une magnifique
tu as vingt mille fans qui l'attendent
que toi l'adorent tu va déchirer
t'as intérêt à décrocher mon pote
[Musique]
c'est pas une poupée
ce truc qui était un vrai poison
condé moi tout ce que vous pouvez sur ce
type
[Musique]
suffit de regarder autour de nous tout
le monde est à croiser truc
[Musique]
10 heures
l'entrée
on a un donneur qui va pas tarder dans
37 minutes à quand remonte son arrêt
cardiaque
17h15 bon allez y
activer la séquence
nous allons répliquer l'esprit humain
nous allons prendre son cerveau
biologique et le dupliquer dans ce
cerveau artificiel
on s'apprêtait à activer la pression de
ronald toute fonction activée qui arrive
[Musique]
essayez tout est temps pour vous
éveillez
marie
j'ai mis aux arrêts
et s'il se passe quelque chose
d'horrible on fait quoi
il s'est déjà passé quelque chose
d'horrible
il
parler de vous dans le journal les une
grosse part de mensonge mais j'imagine
que c'est pas très grave
je suis pas un enfant de choeur vous
êtes billy le kid
mon père a battu ma mère à mort faut
qu'on se fasse discret vous nous emmenez
avec vous
je
ça fait combien de temps que tu es
shérif de semaine là je suis vraiment
flatté
quand il commence à parler de toi tu es
un homme marc da couche deuxième ennemi
public numéro un il ya des familles dont
ces cris qui ont souffert des crimes de
cette homme sortait beaux-arts tu
devrais en faire autant pâte moi je
profite de la vie il faut seulement boni
vient chercher romero
[Musique]
m
vous pensez pouvoir mais chalet personne
n'a besoin de mourir aujourd'hui ce que
c'est pas une des dures réalités de la
vie
projet papa de plus il se sera tout
dernier
vous croyez vraiment je suis comme vous
je sais que c'est mon jour de chance
merveilleux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu crois que je ferais si
tu touches à un seul de ses cheveux
j'emmène mon neveu avec moi ils vont
tous dire que tu es une poule mouillée
et que tu t'es enfui ils savent que
c'est des conneries on s'en fout que ce
soit vrai ou pas l'important c'est
l'histoire qui vont raconter une fois
que tu seras plus là
[Musique]
alors il est où l'échantillon piotr
boris volkov n'est pas le genre de
personne à qui il faut chercher des
noises
[Musique]
piotr a vendu à sam se meuvent des
diamants mais diamant des fois c'est de
la très grande qualité nouvelles
techniques
il est faux le plus beau que j'ai jamais
vu vous devez être plus sélectifs parce
que les amis que vous avez aujourd'hui
vous trompent ceux qui j'imagine est un
problème parmi d'autres ce que vous
aviez à faire c'était de vous procurer
un échantillon 1 un petit diamant
je vous dis nous méfier vous rentrez
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
et l'impression que vous avez des ennuis
je voulais juste faire appel à votre
patience
la patience monsieur il sait comme
l'oxygène dans une pièce close
peu importe combien vous en avait au
départ vous finissez toujours par en
manquait on va pouvoir commencer
[Musique]
les diamants sont ils n'ont
tu me détestes dans la vie rien n'arrive
par hasard
réfléchissez à cette théorie un moment
[Musique]
toutes vos initiatives personnelles
professionnelles
charlene je devais absolument être
disposé à faire des choix qui seront
difficiles à vous comporter de façon
ignoble mais aussi à risque et vos biens
les plus inestimable
parce que tout ce qui a de la valeur ne
sera jamais obtenue sans faire des
sacrifices
[Musique]
maintenant que votre objectif est plus
concret
[Musique]
pensez vous toujours qu'il ya des
limites à ne pas franchir pour défendre
une course dans notre cas ce serait une
nuit seul avec votre mari cela
constituerait une position acceptable
pour une offre ferme de financement de
votre entreprise
tu sais quoi exactement sur un an gomery
les choses pourraient devenir
extrêmement dangereuse
les choses ont toujours été dangereux
ça
tu voteras d'imaginer qu'elle lui aurait
jeté en fait j'ai conscience d'avoir
commis une erreur je mérite pas de
perdre tout ce que j'ai tout ce que je
regrette c'est d'avoir eu le malheur de
croiser votre chemin et combien de gens
vont devoir s'ouvrir pour que vous
arriviez à vos fins vous avez suivi
votre intuition sans penser que vous
vous impliquerez les votants
pire des victimes qu'ils soient et celle
qui choisit d'en faire une autre à son
tour je suis victime de personne
[Musique]
etes-vous absolument certaine que c'est
le choix que vous voulez faire je ne
suis pas celle que vous croyez pas
encore je commence à avoir du potentiel
en
[Musique]
réussir à n'importe quel prix
il
salut je m'appelle moritz et mme ehrman
j'ai 17 ans et ça là c'est ma génération
la génération z
la technologie nous offre des
possibilités infinies et qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait des feuilles soient franchement
qu'est ce qui te fait croire que toi tu
vas réussir mieux que les autres
appellent tous les gens qui ont réussi
étaient des nerd avant l'heure
d'aujourd'hui big boss demain et c'est
quoi le plan comment vendre de la drogue
sur internet
ou alors ça c'est l'idée la plus
criminelle que tu aies jamais eu il
paraît que vous vendez de l'excellent
acheter de l'ecstasy si on se lançait
que ça marche on pourra faire tout ce
qu'on veut
première règle du ciom il est interdit
de parler du chat fight club jamais vu
bon combien tu en veux tous les stocks
vingt-et-une commandant trois jours ça
diraient qu'on aille faire un peu la
fête ce soir ça y est il est là le bon
moment tu veux quoi et casser la gueule
c'est pas exclue d'accord alors tu peux
entrer j'ai pas donner le reste de
l'argent aux dealers il est où le fric
je vous donnerai bientôt friture premier
mauvaise réponse je vous le donne tout
de suite à part dont c'était la bonne
réponse
si si c'est bien ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]